w today I'm going to be speaking with Naomi Klein,
who is senior correspondent at The Intercept
and also author of How to Change Everything.
Naomi, great to have you on today. Happy to be
with you. I've been engaging in this conversation
with many in my audience about how we sort of make
progress on a lot of different issues that come
down to what people know and what people believe.
Certainly, climate change would be on that list at
a more micro level. You know, even beliefs about
what happened in the November of twenty twenty
election would count beliefs about how vaccines
work, beliefs about the messages we get from the
CDC and others. And I believe that there's really
no simple fix here. I think that this is probably
a multigenerational project. Folks have been sort
of indoctrinated into many of the orthodoxies
that now plague us, starting, I would argue,
going back to the Reagan era with stories of
welfare queens and and so on and so forth,
is I'm curious as to the reason for for
sort of writing this book to be accessible
to younger readers. Is it at least partially an
acknowledgment of the the battle we're up against
here? That will be quite a long battle.
That's an interesting question.
You know, I didn't think about it in that way
of like, get them while they're young. I I
really wrote the book directed at young readers
because this book is it's my first book that is
for young readers. It's it's really geared
towards like middle school and early high school.
And it's really because this is where the
energy of the climate movement is right
now. You know, I was on the board of three
fifty dog for a decade and was part of a
kicking off the fossil fuel divestment movement,
which was very much university aged students.
And and those university students are still
involved in all kinds of activism, as you know.
But the energy of the climate movement is now
coming from younger than that. It's it's like it's
the greatest generation. And so and so that's why
I wanted to write a book for this kind of I see a
real generational shift. And I wanted to arm those
young people with the facts and figures to to to
make them better activists and to and to keep
them in this in the struggle for the long term.
You seem to go at what are frequent
misconceptions among adults. I mean,
I think what's interesting is that the
issues you're addressing aren't particularly
different because the audience is younger.
It's just eventually folks with misunderstandings
get older and then they become adults with a lot
of a lot of the same misunderstandings. As an
example, you go with this idea of climate change
isn't just it's warmer everywhere all the time
we're talking about. There could be a warming
overall of the oceans with a radically hot and
cold weather, the way we've seen in Texas and in
other places, the issues seem to be quite similar,
as if you were addressing an adult audience.
Yeah, look, the information in this book is
not substantively different than than
the information in books I've written for
for older readers. It's not dumbed down. It's
just kind of simplified in. A lot of people told
me that they think that the book would be actually
suitable for adults that they know, which may well
be true. And I'm not going to comment on that. I
mean, because we didn't dumb it down. We just kind
of carried it down, simplified it. And the fact
is, the first book I wrote about climate change,
this changes everything has 70 pages of notes.
I mean, it's really like it's just very backed
up and it's really about bringing the receipts and
proving and reproving, because when that book was
published in twenty fourteen, making the argument
that it's sort of the core drivers of capitalism
and neoliberal, the neoliberal project, they're at
the root of why we failed to address this crisis
was treated as a really, really radical idea. And
so I really needed to back it up. But I think that
having a more sort of simplified handbook can be
helpful for for people of all ages. But at one
point, I would want to make about what you were
just bringing up the start around, you know,
around and around this multigenerational
project. I would say that there's some really
interesting research that shows that the most
effective communicators at changing minds are
the young are the daughters of climate
change deniers or people who believe that
it's real. But there's nothing that we can
do rather than hearing somebody on television
lecture them. What the research finds, actually,
is that parents are being swayed by their kids.
Their kids are pushing them around the dinner
table and saying, what are you doing about
this? I'm really frightened. I want something
different. So it turns out that that when we
reach kids, we actually do reach their parents.
We've we've all seen stories of a lifelong,
typically Republican elected official who had
homophobic beliefs for a long time. And then
it turns out that they have an LGBT child in
their family or nephew or something like that,
and they ultimately revisit their beliefs and
they come out with a different view. And and
that's that's sort of good at the maybe what we
would call the retail level. But depending on
everyone having like a personal experience could
be difficult, if that's what we're counting on.
I'm wondering how this would apply to climate
change, where to some degree does the cultural
shift need the repercussions to be more real
and tangible to individuals before they may be
fully willing to to consider that they
may have been led astray on this issue?
Well, the first thing I would just say is that
people are already experiencing the impacts of
climate change and this is very, very widespread.
And so I think it's important to clearly explain
how something like what just happened in Texas
may well be linked with warming, destabilized
climate. Certainly the wildfires that people are
living with every summer in the Pacific Northwest
is definitely linked to climate change. Certainly
more ferocious summer storms are linked to warming
oceans. So we need to be making those arguments
that it isn't like I just want to be clear that
it's not like, oh, we have to wait till things
get really bad and then people will understand.
This is, of course, that things are really bad.
And we need to make those arguments. We
need to make those connections. Yeah.
So in terms of I mean, I guess your
thoughts about the cultural change that
that because with a lot of these things, as we
know, it's not about hammering facts necessarily.
So I guess the other thing I would just I would
just emphasize and it's just my perspective,
I feel like some of your questions are coming
from are emphasizing what I would describe as
the hard deniers, right? Yes. Kind of like the
hardest to reach kind of Fox News addicted.
You know, it's all a Chinese hoax, like really,
really dug in. Right. Climate change deniers. And
I actually don't spend a ton of time thinking
about how to reach the hardest to reach. I
think that there's more productive work to
be done in in sometimes described as the soft
climate deniers or people who actually don't deny
the reality of climate change at all believe it is
happening. But what they believe is that we're too
we're too far gone. It's human nature. And we're
we're never going to really think about the future
kind of climate. Duma's more than climate deniers.
And I think we actually make
a mistake by overemphasizing
reaching the hardest to reach most. Doug,
in most invested in that denial mindset
while ignoring a much easier to reach middle
middle terrain of people who know it's happening,
but feel kind of hopeless about doing anything
about it. Right. That's interesting. Yeah.
If we if we do a good job, if we do a
good job of reaching the soft deniers,
do the hard deniers even matter
as much a matter much, much less.
Because in fact what the polling shows is that a
majority of Americans know that climate change is
happening. A lot of people think it's too late.
A lot of people think have bought the idea that
you have to choose between good jobs and acting
on climate. So there's a ton of work to be done
working with trade unions, organizing workers
in different sectors and and really designing
a future that people are willing to fight for.
Right. That's what a green new deal is about.
And breaking that sort of false dichotomy between
job, job, choosing between jobs and caring about
the environment, I think it's very productive.
How do you suggest approaching those who
maybe are in that that middle group where they
acknowledge that it's happening? They probably
even acknowledge that at least some part of
it is because of human activity, if not all.
But they don't like what they believe to be the
solutions which might in their minds include
we might not be able to have cars
anymore. We'd be restricted on travel.
We might have to keep our houses at fifty five
degrees. And you know that they don't like what
they believe. The lifestyle implications are.
Right. And they believe that because they've been
lied to. Right. They believe that because
there's been a very systematic campaign
to latch on to a throwaway joke that AOC made
about banning cow farts to claim that they're
going to come and seize the cattle and and and
ban airlines forever, things like that. Yeah,
that's been a deliberate campaign to scare people.
And so, you know, I think a lot of these arguments
are not going to be won with arguments. They're
going to be won with facts. They're going to be
won with with people's lived experiences. And this
is where I think that it's useful to think about
some of FDR strategies in rolling out the original
New Deal. The Green New Deal is is modeled after
and it's not it's not an imitation. It's
also it's also a corrective in lots of
ways and problems with the original New Deal.
But it's inspired by the original New Deal
in the. Scale in the mobilization, in the idea
that we need a mission, right? The original New
Deal was not a narrow poverty alleviation program
in the middle of the Great Depression. It was a
new governing framework that affected every aspect
of life. It was dozens and dozens of policies.
And that's the kind of ambition that we
need in the face of a crisis that touches
every part of our lives. Right. The reason we
get overwhelmed in the face of the climate crisis
is because we know that it isn't going to be
solved by changing our light bulbs like we
were told for a couple of decades. Right. I mean,
it affects every aspect of our lives. And we've
never had a policy framework on the scale of
the crisis that we face. So coming back to FDR,
he was very smart in in where he cited a new deal.
Projects like if you map where FDR planted CCC
projects, for instance, the Civilian Conservation
Corps, which is responsible for around eight
hundred state parks, planted more than two billion
trees, employed around three million young people.
He deliberately cited those CCC camps in the parts
of the country that voted against it. And if you
look at the election results in nineteen thirty
six, he flipped many of those red rural areas
blue. And they didn't do it with arguments.
They did it with facts on the ground.
They did it with this is services that are
improving your community, improving daily life,
creating jobs. And people saw it and they liked
it and they wanted more. And so I think that this
is this should be a challenge for the Democrats.
They have lost rural America and we can't write
off rural America. We need to invest. And it isn't
going to be about having the perfect argument and
the perfect messaging. It's going to be about what
is this huge green infrastructure program going to
look like? Who's going to benefit from it? How how
is that going to be message once being rolled out?
And that is way more important than some abstract
debate that we could have about. No, no, no.
It's not going to kill jobs, not show people the
jobs, change people's daily lives for the better.
Yet along those lines, I mean, I'd love to kind
of wrap our conversation talking legislatively.
We know Joe Biden does not support the Green
New Deal, but took many elements from it in
putting together what his proposal was before
he was elected. And of course, we will now see
if after this covid relief bill is done, whether
that is very high on the list of priorities and
sort of what happens. Do you think that if it if
it doesn't happen during these two years during
which Democrats know they control the House,
Senate and White House, that it really becomes
a question mark as to if and when it happens? I
mean, do you think it's urgent that it be done
not just from the scientific standpoint, where
obviously it's urgent, but politically as well?
Yeah, it's urgent on both fronts, right? This
is our window. We are now in what we call the
decade of the Green New Deal. Right. And frankly,
I don't really care about the branding of it. You
want to call it built back better? I don't care.
What matters is that it's guided by science and
justice. And and and as long as those core
principles are there that we are staying
within our carbon budget of keeping temperature
warming below one point five degrees Celsius,
doing everything we possibly can, and
I don't care what you call it, if 40
percent of the green infrastructure is actually
going to be for front line communities of color
based on core environmental justice principles,
I don't care what you call it. Right, because
you're taking the core ideas behind the Green New
Deal and behind the just transition. I mean, the
truth is these ideas have gone by many names over
the years. When I wrote this changes everything,
I started it with a quote from a Bolivian climate
change negotiator who called for a Marshall Plan
for planet Earth. That's what they called it in
2009. We've called it the leap in Canada. I don't
care what you call it, what we do. And we have two
years. You're absolutely right. We have two years
to convince people with their lived experience,
not convince people on television, convince people
that their lived experience and communicating
the ideas and the reality behind these policies
because we just can't lose any more time.
We have lost decades talking and not
acting scientifically, environmentally and and
politically urgent. I think we would certainly
agree. The book is How to Change Everything.
And Naomi Klein, the book's author, is
senior correspondent for The Intercept.
So great having you on today.
Thank you. It's been a pleasure. Take care. Bye.